I think we can kind of get at some of these issues with
a randomized hillclimbing quiz. So what was, kind of what is the
advantage of, of doing hillclimbing and, and what does it lead to
in terms of being able to find the maximum. So, so here, [LAUGH]
yeah, Charles, this is going to be a quiz, and I, I guess
you're not particularly happy about it. But let's, let's take a look
here. We've got an input space of 1 to 28, the integers.
And so here it is kind of out on the screen, all the
values from 1 to 28. And here's the fitness function, or the objective
function for each of those points. It sort of follows this, not exactly
sawtooth, kind of piecewise, jaggy, I don't know what to call it.
>> Drunk.
>> [LAUGH] It is what it is.
>> [LAUGH]
>> And, here's the the global optimum.
And what we're going to do is, we're going to run randomized hill
climbing. And we're going to run it this way. We're going to assume that
the algorithm chooses randomly, in both, if both directions improve. So
it just flips a coin 50-50, then it does whatever evaluations it
needs to do to figure out which way to move to
go uphill. We'll use as of the neighborhood of x to be
the thing immediately to its left and immediately to its right,
unless of course you're at 1 or 28, in which case there's
just one neighbor. So we're just going to use a simplification of the
hillclimbing that we had before. Which is, it's going to check the neighbors,
check both the neighbors if there's two of them, and if one of
them is an improvement, it's going to go in that direction. If neither of
them improvement then it's going to declare itself at a local optimum. And
if both are an improvement, it's just going to flip a coin to decide
where to go. And once it gets to the, to the local optimum,
let's say it sort of climbs up this hill and ends up at this
peak here, it's going to realize that it's at the, at
a local optimum, and then it's going to trigger random restart
and pick a new x position to start at. And
now, the question is, how many function evaluations on average is
it going to take to find x star, the, the tippy-top
of this peak? So, you know, maybe you could write
code to do this, or maybe you could do it
with math. This is probably a little bit more involved than
most of our quizzes, but it should give you a chance
to really dive in and get a feel for this notion
that it matters kind of where these basins of attraction are.
Alright, you think that's clear enough to give it a shot?
>> Sure.
>> Alright, let's go.